اعلنت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في اليوم
ال9 لحربه على قطاع غزه ارتكب 10 مجازره
بحق عائلات في قطاع غزه ادت لوقوع
128 شهيدا
و261 جريحا تقول وزاره الصحه في القطاع ان
حصيله العدوان الاسرائيلي ترتفع بذلك الى
و313 شهيدا والى
و296 اصابه منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
نذهب الان الى مراسلنا من منطقه دير البلح
هشام زقوت هشام اخر المعطيات من الناحيه
الميدانيه
الانسانيه اخر المعطيات هي استمرار للقصف
الاسرائيلي المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تكثف
قصفها وعمليات القصف مركزه على مناطق
البريج والنصيرات والمغازي وهذه المناطق
باتت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف منذ عده ايام
الجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف قصفه لمخيم البريج
والمغازي لا سما المناطق الشرقيه ايضا هو
يحاصر مخيم البريج ويقصف كل من يحاول
الدخول الى هذا المخيم يمنع سيارات
الاسعاف من الدخول وايضا هناك ما زالت
العشرات من العائلات الفلسطينيه محاصره في
هذا المخيم ويمنع التحرك في هذا المخيم
هناك ايضا طائرات مسي
تطلق النار على كل ما يتحرك في مخيم
البريج لكن القصف الجديد هو في مخيم
النصيرات لا سما المناطق الشرقيه في مخيم
النصيرات نحن نتحدث عن حي الفاروق نتحدث
عن حي عين جلوت والذي تتواجد فيه ابراج عن
جلوت منذ صباح هذا اليوم والجيش
الاسرائيلي يقصف هذا الحي بشكل مكثف يطلق
قنابل دخانيه يطلق قنابل فسفوريه على هذا
الحي وايضا يقصف وقصف باحزمه ناريه كثيفه
هذا الحي والمناطق المحيطه به وبالتالي
عمليات القصف ما تزال مستمره ايضا القصف
المدفعي بات يصل الى مديات بعيده الى
منطقه الزوايده حيث ايضا استهدفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه منازل هناك ونقل عدد من
الاصابات الىى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ايضا
المناطق الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات تتعرض ما
بين الفينه والاخرى الى قصف مدفعي عنيف في
تلك المنطقه والاستهداف ما زالت متواصله
ومباشره على المنازل وعمليات ايضا اطلاق
النار ما تزال مستمره ومتواصله على ايضا
المنازل اطلاق النار يتم اما من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه او حتى من الطائرات
المسيره التي تطلق النار على حتى الناس
والنازحين الذين يحاولون جلب بعض الامتعه
من هذه المناطق التي باتت تسقط فيها
القذائف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ويحاولون
اللجوء الى دير البلح التي باتت ملجا
للكثير من الفلسطينيين رغم الازدحام
الشديد في كل المناطق التي يتواجد فيها
السكان والنازح حون ومراكز الايواء في
المستشفى هنا في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى تحول
هذا المستشفى الى مركز للايواء ولا يوجد
فيه متسع ولكن رغم رغم كل ذلك الناس ما
زالت مصره على القدوم الى هذا المستشفى
لانه لا يوجد مكان لديها تذهب اليه الناس
عشرات من السكان وعشرات من العائلات باتت
هذه الليله في العراء والان هي موجوده في
العراء رغم بسبب عملي القصف الاسرائيليه
المتواصله في خانيونس استطاعت طواقم
الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني التوجه الى
منطقه القراره وانتشلت عدد من الشهداء
والجرحى بعدما كانت هذه المناطق صعبه
الوصول بل مستحيله في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي هناك ايضا في مناطق وسط
خانيونس ما زال القصف الاسرائيلي متواصل
وما بين الفينه والاخرى يسمع دوي انفجارات
شديده في ظل تحليق مكثف للطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وعلى ما يبدو انها ناجمه عن
مزيد من الاستهدافات في تلك المنطقه ايضا
المناطق الشرقيه لرفح تتعرض ما بين الفينه
والاخرى الى قصف مدفعي عنيف وهي المناطق
التي تقع الى الى شرق معبر رفح وهو المعبر
الذي الوحيد الذي تدخل من خلاله الان
المساعدات الى كافه انحاء قطاع غزه وهي
مساعدات بحسب السلطات هنا هي مساعدات
شحيحه و العمليه وتيره دخول هذه المساعدات
ما زالت بطيئه ولا تكفي احتياجات هؤلاء
السكان الذين باتوا يتجمعون في منطقتين
اساسيتين هما مدينه دير البلح ومدينه رفح
وايضا رغم هذا التجمع وطلب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من السكان التوجه الى هاتين
المنطقتين الا ان القصف الاسرائيلي ايضا
مستمر ومتواصل وفي كل مره في في هاتين
المنطقتين اقصد ورغم كل ذلك القصف
الاسرائيلي مستمر ومتواصل في هاتين
المنطقتين و السكان في كل مره يدفعون
ضريبه هذا القصف من بينهم شهداء واصابات
في كل لحظه يتم فيها قصف اسرائيلي جديد
على تك الم هشام زقو شكرا جزيلا لك